mesdames et messieurs, veuillez accueillir les
jeunes mariés mr et mme simon doyle
vous devez rencontrer archul puero mes
félicitations madame pitié
il n'est que le plus grand détective vivant
je soupçonne que vous m'avez invité pour des raisons
autres que le plaisir
vous avez eu quelque chose de si haut nous avons le
karnak pour nous tous seuls  un chef et
assez de champagne pour remplir le nil
quand tu as de l'argent personne n'est jamais
vraiment ton ami
il est trop tard pour changer les événements il est temps de
faire face à la conséquence
quelqu'un est mort
de vous étiez-vous au courant de toute
rancune madame est habituée à obtenir ce
qu'elle veut plus
jamais
je ne me sens pas en sécurité ici
je ne me sens en sécurité avec aucun d'eux
il y a tellement de haines et de jalousies contradictoires
oh j'aime ça tu as vu  ou entendre
quoi que ce soit
je ne lui faisais pas confiance je ne sais toujours pas qu'avez
-vous fait la nuit dernière vous m'avez accusé de
meurtre
il accuse tout le monde de meurtre c'est un
problème j'admets
que le meurtre a été méthodiquement blâmé
[Musique]
peut  je ne te fais pas confiance qu'est ce que tu veux que je
te dise